so like how did you transition from
university life to
like your working youtube schedule adult
life the real adult life or whatever we
want to call it
so i think for me i'd finish university
i broke it to my parents that i didn't
want to do a masters
yeah they were like fair enough you
clearly didn't want to do a bachelor's
which i did i passed it with a good
grade so that's fine
yeah and i was like you know what i go
to london a lot why not [ __ ] move to
london yeah on a whim
i moved to japan on the win went there
and just uh
that was kind of it really because when
you met sydney for the first time we had
you already decided that you're going to
london
yeah yeah i knew pretty much like i was
i wanted like about halfway through my
last year of university i was like
i don't like wales anymore yeah i really
really like london
right so i'm going to move to london and
i know the prices were like insane
yeah managed to find a roommate to help
me split the costs and yeah and then
just kind of
went into it and it was really weird
because it was like i don't know just
doing the same [ __ ] in just a different
city i guess
yeah but like no one like teaches you
about that [ __ ] yeah you just gotta do
it and just hope for the best and you're
like oh [ __ ] i have to pay taxes how do
i figure that out and it's like oh [ __ ]
okay i need to figure this out i have to
check the mailbox
yeah yeah just so many things you have
to like figure out and hope that you're
doing right
yeah yeah i don't know like what was it
for you like because obviously you did
like a way bigger
like leap yeah because i mean i
i had like a gap year where you know
in in between from in between actually
starting uh between graduating from uni
and actually starting my job at the bbc
yeah and that was when i kind of went
like that was when i went all out on
youtube before i just completely stopped
yeah so that the period before i
completely stopped i i like spent a lot
of time on youtube because i had
basically nothing else were you still
not making any money during that time
yeah i wasn't making any money oh [ __ ]
um it was just
because i had nothing else to do and i
was really enjoying it
and yeah because that was about what
about the time like potaku started and a
lot of a lot of new things right right
you pretty happy invested in it yeah i
was pretty heavily invested in that
and i remember i this was like such a
weird year for me because i would spend
my time like all over the world
um just in different places like i i
lived in china for a bit
really yeah yeah why huh
um reasons i don't really want to get
into but i
i i was there for a bit and then i was
in thailand for a bit and most of the
time i was just working on youtube
videos
and by the time by the end i just i
wanted something stable i wanted a job i
thought i wanted a job at the bbc
right i thought wrong
and it was it was good for the first
year about the first year was it was a
good experience it was like yes this is
this is a nice break from university and
and just like doing youtube for a while
because
what i didn't realize is how hard
university life is compared to of
having a real job yeah like you you guys
don't know but
the [ __ ] the stress and [ __ ] you go
through in uni is like
10 times as much as anything you'll go
through oh yeah
yeah you've got like drama on top of
having to do like
10 assignments all at one time and yeah
yeah yeah yeah
because it's like if i fail one
assignment i am stuck here for the rest
of my life yeah like i
i've been stressed but never as stressed
as i was at university oh yeah yeah yeah
because they all
always i don't know if it's the same for
you guys but in my university they
always put like all the deadlines
at the same time yeah yeah so it was
always like
two months of like i'm having a great
time playing league of legends 12 hours
a day got nothing to do
and then boom november hits you have
eight [ __ ] assignments two exams
coming up yeah
four exams on top of that two exams that
you have and you're like holy [ __ ] it's
constantly
[ __ ] in your pants yeah yeah yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna die
i'm never gonna get out of this yeah